You're an interesting man.
You have a daughter.
Your dad.
You're an avenger.
Have I killed you before?
on February 17th, I can shattered
existence and nothing can prepare you.
You may not want her to watch this
for the new dynasty.
Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania.
PG 13 Experience in 3D February 17.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
Marvel released a new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania via Kang scene,
where he talks about killing The Avengers
and not remembering which Avengers
it was meaning.
He's face many variants of the Avengers
team from alternate universes before this,
so we'll break it all down and explain
how he got those scars.
What happens if you mess with time?
It tends to mess back the scene.
If you bring new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're doing an IMAX
to give away for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your predictions
for Kang in the comments below.
All be sure to name a new winner
during this too.
During the new trailer,
when Ant-Man is meeting
Kang the Conqueror for the first time,
he has no idea who Kang is because
everyone had been separated
when Kang locked on to Cassie Lane.
Signal.
That's him
here, pulling them into the quantum realm.
And at that point, Janet Van Dyne hadn't
told them about her history with Kang.
She doesn't do that till later.
In the movie,
Kang winds up capturing Cassie Lang in
Ant-Man and brings them to principal
as his time city.
That's based on
the principle is from the comics.
Ant-Man rolls up boasting
about how he's a member of The Avengers.
They just defeated two versions of Thanos
in Save the Universe.
He wrote a bestselling book,
Look Out for the Little Guy, which Marvel
actually just released a trailer
for like a separate, funny trailer,
as if they actually created the book
because it actually
sounds like
they're selling that real book.
But the book itself in Real
life is just a compilation,
like a retrospective on his character
in the MCU, an Avenger,
but he's also a bestselling author.
And now you
can purchase my his very real book.
Look Out for the little Guy.
That's right.
This once movie
prop is now an actual real life book
you can purchase wherever books are sold.
How's that for meta?
And when he's boasting about being part
of The Avengers, you better watch out.
Kang completely unperturbed
replies, You're an Avenger.
Have I killed you before?
Are you the one with the hammer?
There's a big Thor reference
that they cut out of the trailers,
but it's Kang revealing that he's fought
and killed many variants of the Avengers
team for across different universes.
It's also a reference
to a lot of the old battles
he had against The Avengers in the comics.
With the change that it's Kang
conquering different universes
instead of simply fighting The Avengers
within his own timeline.
Many different times in the comics
and in the animated series
where they have been doing
Kang for a while now.
Usually it's just one version of Kang
fighting them at different points
in his own timeline.
There's also the same way
they explained his backstory in the comics
up to more recent stories,
where they introduced
the whole concept of the Council of Kangs
and the Council of Read's multiverse.
Variants of the team
up across the universes.
They teased that during the Loki
finale with the he remains variant of Kang
during Rick and Morty.
The citadel of Rick's was inspired
by the Council of Reeds
and the Council of Kangs,
but you notice
all the scars that he has on his face,
even in what looked like the flashbacks
where he's not wearing his armor.
He was wearing the green tunic,
which is also inspired
by his classic comics outfit
that's green and purple,
meaning he got the scars
before he crashed in the quantum realm.
The first time he got the scars when
he was busy fighting the multiverse war.
And also while that was happening,
he fought and killed
many of the other variants of the Avengers
in different universes.
Not every single other variant
of the team.
Theoretically, there be infinite universes
with infinite versions of the team
in this particular variant of Kang
the Conqueror
would have only visited some of them.
But they're also explaining that this Kang
variant is the one who actually started
the Kang Multiverse war
in the first place.
As he remained said,
some of them worked together for a time
to better each other's universes,
but some only saw other universes
as new places to conquer.
Thus this variant of Kang the Conqueror.
His joked Ant-Man about forgetting
which avenger
he was,
is a callback to the Spider-Man joke
earlier in the movie,
where the shop owner calls him Spider-Man
incorrectly is a joke that is successful
as he wasn't helping them
find a way to save the universe
and using the quantum realm and time
travel.
Really,
we need to think Chris Pratt for that.
In despite all that, the other Avengers
are meant to be way more popular than him.
Like the one with the Hammer, Thor
in Spider-Man, for instance.
That's also a joke in real life too.
Like collectively, Spider-Man
is probably one of the most popular
characters in all of comics
in the history of the real world.
Whereas Ant-Man is just like this
super small kind of niche thing,
metaphorically and literally.
One of the other jokes about merch
sales, too,
like just how much money has Ant-Man
earned for Marvel as a character,
Is that during the movie
they're explaining Scott Lang
earning a bunch of money on merch
that he's selling for himself.
Like the little kid
has an Ant-Man backpack.
But the art on the backpack is based
on posters from the actual first movie.
In real life, Sorkin really needs to take
a couple of lessons from him
and how to merchandise his celebrity
after Avengers Endgame
because he can't get a bank loan.
It sounds like he barely has any money.
If any man has been this successful
in starting a podcast, writing a book
and selling all this merchandise,
it feels like some of the other Avengers
could probably glom onto this idea.
But one of the reasons
why Kang started the Multiverse war
and this is another connection
to his comics backstory,
is that in the 30th century
where he's born as Nathaniel
Richards on Earth, it's
called the time of plenty No one Wants for
anything is so advanced,
there's no hunger, disease, war, chaos.
They've sold pretty much every problem
that the world has.
People still get into fights, they still
get injured, they still hate each other.
Like everything isn't totally perfect.
But the technology in their practices
are so advanced
that you could get your arms severed
or your throat slashed in.
A medic would be able
to patch you up in seconds
with something like a Band-Aid
and you'd be good to go.
Regular school children are so intelligent
that they make Iron Man
and Mister Fantastic or the Fantastic
Four look like they're cavemen.
And Kang is born one of these children.
He grows bored with life.
In that time,
nothing interesting ever really happens
because they've learned
to control everything.
So he takes Dr.
Doom's designs for his time
travel platform out of the archives,
uses them to build his things.
Time ship
takes them back to ancient Egypt,
where he sets himself up as the ruler.
Romita
the Fantastic Four in the 20th century,
detect this,
use their technology to stop him.
Eventually he gets bored
with that adventure,
fighting them in escapes,
going back to the future.
Well, setting up the mutant apocalypse
in ancient Egypt as his successor,
who then goes on to bargain with
the Celestials for even more technology.
As long as he helps,
Aaron, the judge continue his plan
for growing the population as fast as
possible to speed the development of tea
in the Earth's core.
Nathaniel Richards,
who escaped back to the future winds
up overshooting his home
period of the 30th century and winds up
arriving in the 31st century with access
to even more advanced technology.
Using that, he starts calling himself
Kang the Conqueror
and returns back to the 20th century again
to fight The Avengers.
In that time period in over time,
he just continued doing that, jumping
backwards
and forwards in time, using different
technology, different monikers like
the Scarlet Centurion, so on and so forth.
In the MCU,
the difference is that a lot of those
different encounters
with different Avengers went down with
different variants of Kang in the fights.
This Kang the Conqueror experience
happened in different universes.
Kang's typical go to move is to offer
people deals like he's offering
Ant-Man in the trailers.
He did the same thing for Loki and Sylvie
into Janet Van Dyne,
even though in each cases
it was a slightly different
variants of Kang the Conqueror.
Same basic premise, though he tells them,
Help me and I can give you what you want.
Usually it involves reinserting them
into a version of their timeline,
making alterations to that timeline
to give them whatever they want most.
But secretly it's all a lie.
Usually winds up happening, as did
with his big army here that he assembled
in the quantum realm
is that he tricks people into his service
or accepting his deals
and they never wind up getting out of it.
He winds up trapping them into a life
of servitude through threads or forms,
or just stringing them along
with more promises, which is why Janet Van
Dyne is telling Scott not to be a fool
and accept his deal because it's a lie.
He'll give him back his time
with Cassie Lang.
But the second that that time starts, they
get reinserted back into that timeline.
Kang is going to wipe out the entire
timeline itself, so it won't matter.
It'd be like dropping
a bunch of goldfish back into a tank
and then smashing the tank.
That's what Gina van Dyne
is talking about, erasing whole timelines.
And that's another reference back to
the Loki series, The Kang Multiverse War,
and what Kang plans on doing in Avengers
five Qing Dynasty.
Here's the other cool new rumor
about Avengers six Secret Wars, too.
There's rumors that they're actually going
to split it into two parts,
meaning that they did that Avengers secret
words.
Part one would be May 2026
and they'd released part two either
at the end of 2026 or in May 2027.
So potentially we have three Avengers
movies in three consecutive years.
There's a whole lot of Avengers.
I'm not going to complain about that.
That'd be amazing.
But that seems like a lot of Avengers
movies in a really short amount of time.
Remember when they were going to release
Avengers
five and Avengers six in the same year?
I think we all expected them
to delay Avengers six.
Like there's no way
they're going to release two movies
that big in the same year.
They did do something like that
with The Matrix movies
back in the early 2000s,
and at the time it was crazy.
Like I thought it was nuts
that they would try something like that.
If they do wind up splitting Avengers
secret wars, what they probably do
is just expand on the events of both
the original 1980s secret wars
with the Beyond or in the modern version
against God Emperor Doom
because both of those versions of Secret
Wars were so big, so epic,
it be impossible to cram the events
of all those into a three hour plus movie.
You need like six or 7 hours and even then
you be cutting out a ton of stuff.
And during that we'll see a much bigger
on screen version
of the actual Kang Multiverse War,
happening with many variants of Kang.
That's why they keep teasing the Kang
Multiverse War
during the Loki series in Loki Season two.
But we haven't actually seen it
play out on screen yet.
Just because they want to do
a huge crazy version of it.
And when we get to Avengers Secret Wars,
the plot is completely different.
Look, it's a whole different vibe.
Let me know in the comments though.
If they do split Avengers
Secret Wars into two parts,
do you want them to release both parts
in the same year in 2026,
or do you want them to break them up
and just do one Avengers movie
every single year?
There's
a whole bunch of Super Bowl trailers
that I'll be doing videos
for in a couple weeks from Marvel, DC.
A bunch of other people
be sure to enable trailers for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Congratulations Bandido, for
you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here
for my other new Kang Video and click here
for my New Black Panther.
What kind of forever deleted scene
in Secret Invasion Connections?
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.